what's going on guys this is rob and
word has reached my ears at least rumors
anyway that the illuminati are going to
appear in doctor strange too i don't
know if that's actually going to be the
case and in all honesty youtube will
probably demonetize this video just
because of the title but the important
thing here
is the group is rumored to appear in
doctor strange too as part of like the
multiversal capers and on the off chance
that it is we're gonna do a character
explanation on these guys one just two
at the very least kind of make sure you
guys are aware of what's going on with
this group should it appear in doctor
strange too even though we're early and
two because i love the group they're
amazing
and i'm surprised we never did a video
explaining them in the past so the
illuminati first appeared in new
avengers vol 1 issue number seven in
july of 2005 and they were created by
brian michael bendis and steve mcniven
now this idea of the group forming was
part and parcel to what was a story
called who is the century and the idea
behind this is that the century as most
of you guys know it's robert reynolds
the reason why this story is important
to avengers which we did cover it we'll
have a link to it down in the
description is that this was actually
robert reynolds being rolled over into
the main marvel universe following his
initial introduction in marvel nights
which was basically just kind of a
standalone story that was out there you
could almost consider it to be like a
what if story right just an alternate
reality and then once he was rolled in
that entire history actually became
continuity so it was a pretty
interesting concept if not a little bit
confusing in terms of this but in the
aftermath of all this what you actually
saw was the illuminati forming now we
didn't really get the nitty-gritty in
terms of how the group actually formed
what their motivations were what they
were shooting for until we got the
miniseries by brian michael bendis and
what this miniseries did is it actually
gave us this really really cool set of
events insofar as how the group formed
and why now something that i do want to
point out is this was part of the lead
up to the civil war event so it was
really kind of one a one shot they gave
us their initial introduction and then
two the mini series that followed up
they gave us kind of some of the events
they had been involved in and how they
actually spent more time screwing stuff
up than they did getting things right
but the initial formation of the group
actually happened in wakanda and the
reason why is because they wanted to
operate in secret and as most of you
guys know if for no other reason than
just having seen the black panther film
that wakanda is one of those places
where no one gets in and no one gets out
unless the wakandans specifically black
panther allows them to and so this
meeting taking place was allowed by
black panther for a couple reasons one
because of the level of respect he had
for these individual people and two
probably because he was just curious but
the initial formation consisted of reed
richards of the fantastic four iron man
professor xavier the leader of the x-men
doctor strange black bolt of the
inhumans and neymar the submariner now
the way the group initially existed is
they actually presented this idea which
is pretty cool but ultimately never
would have worked the way it was put
forward was that this all happened in
the aftermath of something called the
cree scroll war now we're not going to
get into like the nitty nitty-gritty
details of the crease world war we can
do that at some future point in time if
it becomes incredibly relevant if it
does i imagine it'll be in one of the
captain marvel movies that's coming up
uh that's really where it's been
referenced it's where you've seen the
cree in the scroll the most often but
the idea behind this is that the korean
scroll had basically been waging war for
millions of years right for for eons and
eons and eons and so one of the things
that happened is that during this
conflict because of earth's location and
also because of the superpower beings on
earth it's a very strategic planet that
if there was an event whereby one of
these races were able to conquer earth
which they actually did in the maximum
security storyline that they would be
able to basically enslave the entire
human population and then presumably use
the superhuman population for their own
ends and when you're talking about you
know super intelligent minds like reed
richards or iron man or you're talking
about the powers of people like the
x-men or the avengers this can make a
huge difference in a war against either
the scroll or the cree whichever race
happens to take it and so the war came
incredibly close to earth and it
actually almost saw the earth being
conquered and so because of this when
the team first formed iron man actually
made this argument that what you had was
each one of these guys with a piece of
information that had been shared with
the rest of the superhero community
could have actually prevented the war
from coming as close to earth as it did
and they actually could have helped to
stop it and so the initial idea is that
instead of having individual superhero
factions so the avengers and the x-men
and like the inhumans and the atlanteans
and doctor strange doing his own thing
that instead the entire superhuman
community on earth is one cohesive
community that there are no individual
teams that they all basically work in
unison this was almost universally
rejected by everybody there and for a
variety of reasons right some of them
were because of the fact that they all
had very very shady dealings that were
going on behind the scenes things that
would actually look bad if it happened
in the public eye and more so than that
none of them could really seem to agree
on anything right that the x-men by and
large wanted to remain in isolation they
didn't want to be part of the rest of
the superhero community the avengers
never really cared about what happened
to the x-men neither did the fantastic
four or anybody like that that's
something that's actually been revisited
several times over the course of marvel
comics and in fact is actually one of
the big beefs the x-men have with the
various superhero communities that are
out there right when like friends of
humanity or the right or any one of
those organizations were trying to take
out the mutant population there were no
avengers coming to their rescue and in
fact during the original mutant massacre
in new york thor was the only one who
showed up and it was only because he
happened to be there because
circumstances led him there not because
he knew what was going on or really had
any involvement at all and so it was a
pretty significant thing but the long
and short is that because each one of
these groups just can't really seem to
work together then what these guys
decide to do is to operate in secret to
operate behind the scenes now as you can
imagine that's not going to end well and
in fact that was the case that was made
by black panther when black panther was
extended the offer to become part of the
illuminati he shot it down in fact he
said this is never going to work and a
time will come when the world will
become aware of your existence and when
that happens you will lose all trust and
credibility because they will find out
you are basically manipulating them
behind the scenes that information that
you could have shared that that needed
to be shared with the rest of the world
you kept to yourself and so when that
happens it's all going to come crashing
down now the funny thing about that is
that actual kind of prophecy that belief
of black panther wouldn't become a thing
until much later on in marvel comics
during jonathan hickman's avengers and
new avengers run specifically coming out
of original sin and we'll talk about
that here in a little while but what you
ended up getting following this uh new
avengers illuminati one shot is the
miniseries actually showing us some of
the things they did in the early days
you didn't get it all you just got a lot
of really kind of the broad strokes
right the the more important things and
so one of the first things they done is
that because they formed a week after
the conclusion of the preschool war they
immediately visited the scrolls and they
basically said if you guys bring your
conflict as close to earth as you did
last time we won't go so easy on you
right it was really kind of
strong-arming right trying to like you
know instill fear in the scrolls and in
a lot of ways it worked to a degree just
because again earth is home to so many
incredibly powerful beings but what
actually ended up happening is that the
scrolls themselves actually kidnapped
the illuminati and they started going
through and analyzing their dna and even
duplicating it and so once they release
the illuminati out there the illuminati
had no knowledge of what had happened
they didn't know what the scrolls had
done they thought that they had simply
just escaped the ship and blacked out
for a brief moment and basically they
were on their way out right but they
were like messes delivered you know the
day is saved the funny thing about this
is that their actions in doing that and
the scrolls basically duplicating their
dna and even like absorbing all these
memories and the knowledge of each
member of the illuminati became a very
important plot point during the events
of secret invasion because you ended up
finding out that the scroll homeworld
was destroyed i believe by galactus and
that basically led to them looking for a
new world and because of everything the
illuminati had done they actually
duplicated superheroes they copied
superheroes across the world and even
some humans and so you didn't know who
was a scroll and who didn't know who was
a person it was a really really cool
story it was really really fun but that
was the first thing they did following
that they came to the realization that
the infinity stones needed to be
attained that only each member of the
illuminati could be trusted with an
infinity stone because
they were basically full of hubers they
were incredibly arrogant and so what
they ended up doing was traveling around
gathering the stones together and then
at the 11th hour reed richards actually
got the infinity gauntlet and was sort
of intoxicated by its power and that's
one of the things to know when it comes
to the infinity gauntlet itself that
there's two aspects to this the first is
that the stones want to be reunited now
this was something that was new in the
illuminati comic we'd never seen this
before but we never had marvel
introduced this idea that the stones
were kind of these sentient objects the
closest you got to that was the soul
stone and it actually had a kind of
quote unquote hunger for souls and that
was basically it but in terms of
introducing this idea that like one
stone can lead you to the others because
they all want to be unified it was a
fairly new idea and it made sense given
this kind of unofficial understanding of
the stones in marvel's history the fact
that people like thanos were able to so
easily find the other infinity stones
after retaining one it made sense right
it was just one of those things that
marvel kind of unofficially acknowledged
and then brian michael bendis made an
official thing but with reed richards
being intoxicated by its power that's
the other component it's very very
difficult and it takes a person with an
incredibly high level of mental
fortitude and resilience to be able to
withstand the influence of the infinity
stones it's why thanos was able to do it
because one he's so incredibly
intelligent two he's been around for so
long and three that guy's fortitude is
off the charts
and so when reed richards got it despite
his intelligence he actually wanted to
use it he was like imagine the things
that we could fix with this thing right
now in truth he would be doing it
against the universe's will but it would
be his will in his mind he felt like it
would have been the right thing to do
and so as crazy as it sounds what
actually ended up happening here is two
things one uwatu the watcher appeared to
read richards and said no you cannot use
the infinity gauntlet but reid actually
started to ignore the watcher and became
more and more intoxicated by its power
and two while it's never officially
stated in the comic by brian michael
bendis the implication is that uh
professor xavier used his telepathy to
manipulate the mind of reed richards to
get him to let the the the infinity
gauntlet go and that was one of the
first instances of early rifts among the
illuminati that they would secretly kind
of work against each other depending on
the circumstance and their perception of
the greater good but the important thing
is that once the once the gauntlet was
put away that would follow that was that
each member of the illuminati actually
got an infinity stone to themselves to
keep in a safe place so nobody could
ever get their hands on it now the
following thing after that was actually
the beyonder and this was one of the
more contested points in marvel comics
and in fact fans of the original secret
wars from 1984 and fans of secret wars 2
from 1985 had a big issue with this so
one of the things that happened here for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with that story is the beyonder was just
a being who was there right he just kind
of popped up one day you didn't really
know where he came from and in fact you
didn't really get his origin until you
got to secret wars 2 in 1985 but the
important thing is that the beyonder was
curious about the superheroes on earth
specifically with how like good and evil
existed and so what he did is he
kidnapped what was basically all the
most popular heroes and all the most
popular villains and then had them fight
each other and so following that i guess
ending of that story the beyonder was
even more curious and then actually
traveled to earth and that's really
where the the new avengers illuminati
story focusing on the beyonder takes
place but one of the things that was
really a big contesting point here is
brian michael bendis modified the entire
history of the beyonder in saying that
he was basically an inhuman who was also
a mutant that was exposed to the
terrigen miss so basically an inhuman
with a deactivated gene or a
non-activated gene with mutant powers
when that gene was activated that
explained why he became so
astronomically powerful now an important
thing to understand about that it was
immediately wiped away right like it's
as soon as that happened marvel was like
nope that's not gonna happen in fact uh
jonathan came along and just clean
slated that in truth nobody liked it
nobody was a big fan of it no one wanted
to see that happen and it really seemed
pointless in a lot of different ways now
one of the more important aspects of the
illuminati meeting and probably the most
popular aspect of the meeting was really
the idea of exiling the incredible hulk
and the idea behind this was that there
was a more recent rampage by the hulk
who had basically destroyed las vegas
and that maria hill who at the time was
the director of shield had contacted
tony stark and said something needs to
be done about this and so what had
happened is that the illuminati had
formed a plan that because of the
inherent nature of the hulk the fact
that he's unpredictable violent there is
no limit to how strong he can become
that he really seems to be more of a
threat than anything else that in the
end everybody except for namely the
submariner agreed to banish the hulk
from earth and it was one of those
things where namor had actually
understood where where banner had come
from that in the end despite the raging
of the incredible hulk bruce banner was
one of their own he was a member of the
superhero community and in fact he had
aided them on multiple occasions and for
the illuminati to arbitrarily take it in
their own hands to decide that he's just
too dangerous and he has to go his name
with a submariner off so again more
rifts that existed among the team and so
what they did is they tricked the
incredible hulk onto a spaceship and
then he was initially supposed to go to
a peaceful planet where there were no
conflicts or anything like that and as
most of you guys know from the planet
hulk event he ended up flying through a
gravity well instead and ended up on
cicard and that set the entire stage for
planet hulk which eventually led to
world war hulk once his family right his
wife kiera and his unborn child were
destroyed due to a detonation of the
engine in the ship that he was sent to
sakar on so he basically blamed the
illuminati for the death of his family
again creating more problems for
themselves now following that and
probably one of the last significant
moments for the meeting of the team
before the events of avengers and new
avengers was the idea of civil war now
in reality this is what split the
illuminati but the idea behind this is
you had a mutant by the name of nitro
and nitro was taking something called
mutant growth hormone think of it as
like the mutant version of hgh right
like human growth hormone what some
bodybuilders use in order to increase
their size mgh right the mutant growth
hormone that actually amplified the
powers of mutants and so what you had
was basically a reformed version of the
new warriors right so like richard ryder
nova and all those guys did it basically
become like a reality tv show team in
the sense that they would like track
down villains and bust them on live tv
so imagine like dog the bounty hunter as
a team of super powered beings and that
was basically new warriors at the time
but what ended up happening is they
ambushed nitro who was on mgh and nitro
had the ability to basically let off
massive amounts of energy now up to that
point it was relatively small in scale
but with mgh when he detonated in
stanford it killed hundreds of people
this led to what was basically the
presentation and the formation of the
superhuman registration act that
humanity could not sit idly by any
longer specifically in the states and
just watch as superheroes engage in
these massive conflicts that would
destroy cities things like that and
groups like damage control would just be
left to pick up the pieces now the
secret behind this was that damage
control were the ones who were actually
creating mgh for the purpose of making
sure the superheroes actually increased
the amount of damage that they were that
they were causing which would give uh
damage control even more lucrative
contracts with the federal government
right so it was pretty sinister in
nature but the big thing about this is
that the illuminati initially met at the
outset and the initial proposition of
the superhuman registration act before
the events of civil war even took place
and it was basically presented to the
entirety of the group the only people
who sided with it were tony stark and
reed richards everybody else either
disagreed or chose to abstain from it
and so that's why when you go and you
read the actual civil war event the only
members of the illuminati who are
basically on the same side as far as the
entire you know pro registration act go
are basically tony stark and reed
richards doctor strange stayed out of it
namely the submariner was involved in it
insofar as he was activating basically
sleeper agents and that was basically it
right no one else really wanted to be a
part of this and so the the next big
thing here again not really the group
meeting per se it was more than just
kind of being brought together
forcefully was the world war hulk event
right and we covered that most of the
guys were familiar with that story on
some level where the incredible hull
could return to earth following the
events of of planet hulk and it actually
conscripted the illuminati forced them
to face off against each other and the
day was saved really in two ways right
that uh the century had shown up to face
off against the incredible hulk when
bruce banner was seemingly at his
strongest or the strongest he'd ever
been up to that point and when tony
stark activated his satellites that
basically shut down uh the incredible
hulk in the sense that it forced him to
revert back into his banner form and
that was basically it you had a few
other things here and there right like
secret invasion was there just because
of the fact that the illuminati realized
they were the ones who caused it when
they went to go visit the scrolls and
all that kind of stuff but the important
thing here is that you eventually get
into what's called the avengers the new
avengers run also known as the
incursions and this is probably the
single most important aspect of the
history of the illuminati as a team so
the idea behind the incursions to try to
make it as succinct as i possibly can
at least in terms of the initial
situation basically black panther came
to the realization that universes were
crashing into each other right that this
led to what was essentially a kind of
portal that he couldn't really see with
the human eye but you could tangibly
pass through and when he passed through
it he was still on earth but there was
another earth up in the sky and there
was a girl named black swan along with a
few other people who are going to
detonate this anti-matter bomb and
destroy that world and so ultimately the
world was completely obliterated at
least that other earth was and then
black swan and her forces were were
basically captured by uh black panther
and then in turn he reformed the
illuminati now what followed was
basically a two-part story that kind of
altered back and forth you had what was
called just the avengers run avengers
vol 5. and what you ended up learning is
that run was actually a distraction
right and we'll talk about that here in
a second it was a distraction by the
illuminati the second part was new
avengers and new avengers was basically
just a story focusing on the illuminati
and so as these two things ran their
course what you ended up getting here
was the illuminati trying to find a way
to stop the incursions and then the
avengers just being distracted that what
happened is that once the illuminati
became aware of the incursions that iron
man came up with this idea of forming
what was called avengers world that he
worked with captain america to unify the
entire avengers roster the whole
superhuman community in a way that had
never been done before but that was just
designed to be a great big huge
distraction that was it that's all it
was supposed to be and so ultimately
everything came to a head during the
events of original sin which was
basically when everybody in the world
learned the secrets of everybody else
right but one of the things that you
learned here is that when the illuminati
was reformed by black panther because of
the fact that charles xavier of the
x-men had basically been gone uh
following the events of avengers versus
x-men when he was killed by cyclops that
captain america replaced him and so
captain america was brought in as part
of the illuminati that when the first
incursion on earth took place captain
america got the infinity gauntlet he
pushed the earth away and succeeded
basically staving off an incursion but
destroyed the infinity stones in the
process with the exception of the time
stone which vanished and so basically
there was no real way to save everything
with the exception of doing exactly what
black swan did which was traveling from
world to world and blowing it up and so
because of the fact that captain america
wasn't on board with this basically at
the direction of iron man his mind was
wiped by doctor strange and he was
thrown out and so the entire avengers
run the whole concept of avengers world
was basically done by tony stark to
ensure that captain america and the rest
of the superhero community never became
curious about what iron man and all
those guys were basically doing they
never became aware or never really
became curious about what the illuminati
were doing behind the scenes never had
any reason to ask why tony stark was
missing for months at a time and so with
original sin captain america recalled
all of this now that story coincided
with a captain america story by rick
remender called the nail which was
basically when steve rogers lost the
super soldier serum and that's why you
see this sudden shift where steve rogers
is young and then he's suddenly old
right after he lost the serum his body
basically aged up sam wilson became the
new captain america and you go on from
there and so what this did is it
actually led to what was essentially a
cat and mouse game that the illuminati
were basically out running the avengers
while captain america leading shield and
using the avengers that actually allied
to his side once we once the world
became aware of the incursions and
basically began going through and
chasing down both the illuminati and the
avengers who defected to the side of the
illuminati and so quite literally the
whole incursion event split the
superhero community down the middle now
once you get to eight months later and
time runs out all that goes away people
start to realize how credible of a
threat the incursions are and that the
multiverse is collapsing and basically
the superhero community is reunited
again right the illuminati are working
alongside everybody the the alliance is
tenuous at best i don't mean to say
they're all besties right and in fact
there's one point where captain america
and iron man basically fight to the
death where they're both crushed by a
helicarrier which happened in secret
wars number zero but that's really the
important thing about the illuminati
right i mean ultimately the day's saved
right everything's kind of set back to
normal uh once secret wars ends and you
know i mean the multiverse is destroyed
right don't get me wrong the multiverse
does collapse
and it's really like god king doom and
all kinds of crazy stuff if you're
curious about avengers of new avengers
check out the playlist down in the
description i'll tell you right now it's
one of the greatest comic book stories
ever written but that's the long and
short of the illuminati in marvel comics
the funny thing about this is that as
far as i'm aware we haven't seen them
since they haven't reformed or come back
a time may come when they do and if they
really are going to be in doctor strange
too i wouldn't be surprised if that was
the case but that's basically the
history of the team it's less about the
overall power of the individuals who are
there and more about how they try to
operate behind the scenes in order to
basically ensure and to execute their
own agenda but all the while usually
causing more problems than they solved
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace